باكستان السابق عمران خان ان المحكمه
العليا منحته افراجا بكفاله في جميع
القضايا الرئيسيه المرفوعه ضدها اضاف خان
في مقابله مع الجزيره الطريقه الوحيده
لتحقيق الاستقرار في باكستان تتلخص في
اجراء الانتخابات
اعطتني المحكمه العليا في اسلام اباد
افراجا بكفاله في جميع القضايا الرئيسيه
المرفوعه ضدي الان يمكنني العوده الى منزل
بامان وغدا سنخاطب الامه ونمنحها الامل
عندما كنت في السجن كانت هناك فوضى ولم
يكن لدي اي فكره عن ما كان يحدث لان من
اختطفني عملني كارهابي هذا بلدنا وعلينا
حمايته والطريقه الوحيده لتحقيق ذلك هي
المضي قدما لاجراء الانتخابات من يفكر في
فرض حاله الطوارئ في باكستان هو احمق لان
ذلك سيجر البلد الى الانهيار وتعميق
الازمه